son un emblema de la corona tanto como
ella y el personal real los etiquetó
como una alfombra móvil a la reina
isabel segunda rara vez se le veía sin
sus queridos corbis una raza que amaba
desde la infancia su padre le regaló su
propio cachorro susan cuando cumplió 18
años durante sus 70 años de reinado crió
más de 30 córneas de 14 generaciones de
descendientes de sus años
siempre temí perderla pero estoy muy
agradecida de que su sufrimiento fuera
tan misericordiosamente cortó sus
queridas mascotas también la acompañaron
en un conjunto de retratos para la
revista 'vanity fair' así como durante
su famoso sketch de james bond para los
juegos olímpicos de londres-2012 incluso
creó su propia raza híbrida el dormí con
el dax en de su hermana la princesa
margarita la reina también era una ávida
amazona que disfrutaba manteniendo y
montando sus caballos pero también se
dedicó a la cría y a las carreras de
caballos durante más de seis décadas en
2013 fue captada por las cámaras
mientras su caballo estimate ganaba la
copa de oro en royal ascot la primera
vez que un monarca reinante era
declarado ganador en 207 años
las carreras se convirtieron en uno de
sus eventos sociales favoritos del año y
disfrutó de un total de 24 victorias
aunque no se ha confirmado qué ocurrirá
con los caballos y los amigos peludos de
la reina se espera que permanezcan en la
familia